crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
you ain't got it ask me cuz you can
trust that every to see you already JUCO
above ground cool goes better than most
Jay Larson self-diagnose go down low
this week last week here we go
[Music]
ah
ah yeah
[Music]
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
beasts no the Tuesday bass crappie for
there hey babe very monkish yeah dot
liked it want to start large a lot good
to be a buddy uh what's up everybody Jay
Larson here Dre Lawson comic Andre
Larsen call me all social media budget
tout date so I'll just be tweeting those
out so if you're on the Twitter you can
come out to a show would love to see you
otherwise nothing much for me to report
sickle-cell Ryan Sickler on all social
media Ryan Sickler calm you can catch me
at the Hollywood improv tomorrow night
and this weekend on the 11th the crab
feast calm is where you can get all your
crab feast info love seeing you all bye
and support us with the merch wearing it
out there you all look so good in it and
as always use that Amazon link do all of
your shopping there help us out it's a
free way to help the podcast premium
apps are there if you're into the
premium apps and make sure you follow us
on social media the craft fees Facebook
fan page and at crab feast on Twitter
blue apron this week back again is
number one fresh ingredient and recipe
delivery service in the country blue
aprons mission is to make incredible
home cooking accessible to everyone
blue apron achieves this by supporting a
more sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for ingredients and
building a community of home chefs all
right I got a confession to make I went
out and got a competitor's program
because when we signed up a blue apron
I'm like alright we're gonna do blue
apron I want to see what we're up
against cuz there's so many different
people out there and my hand to God
it blew ever just smokes it it smokes it
the best food no one else is doing what
they do their seafood is sourced
sustainably understand was developed in
partnerships with the Monterey Bay
Aquarium Seafood Watch beef chicken and
pork come from responsibly raised farms
produces source from farms that practice
regenerative farming if you don't know
what that is
basically you're not just ripping up
land after five years you're gonna keep
using land so it continues to grow
amazing amazing amazing company and also
you know I always cook at home for the
family but now Kate and I are cooking
together we love
watching the recipes we keep the cards
you know we get them like a little
three-ring binder so we have them all so
we go back and use them I just made
orange mirin glazed Cod this week I love
black cod I don't know if it was black
okay I made the beef tacos and I still
got that West African chicken ready to
go very different from these staff what
the other thing is is like opens you up
to trying meals that you would never try
so many things you just like oh no I
would order at a restaurant but I know
how to make that at home but even when
I'm eating well I can make like brown
rice and sweet potatoes and [ __ ] you
need to be a chef to make this stuff
like this the other thing I do
especially as a single dad as I over by
and half the food ends up going to waste
with you over by over Fryman with blue
apron it's all portioned perfectly that
there's nothing to waste and here's the
thing the thing that people forget when
you're buying food and cooking at home
when you spend a lot of restaurant or
high-end grocery chains now you spend
under $10 per person for delicious meals
if you if you factor that out look at it
and you'll see how much money you're
saving so here's the deal call tech what
you need to get going on here check out
this week's menu and get your first
three meals free with free shipping by
going to blue apron comm slash crab
feast you'll love how good it feels and
tastes create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue ribbons so don't wait
and if you're gonna like invite a chick
or a dude over for a meal you do this
and you stick it in the fridge it's blue
apron calm slash crab feast blue apron a
better way to cook Valentine's Day is
one week on time today don't sleep on it
don't be the guy or the girl that's like
wait until the last second to get
something done gifts like no other for
your love like no other okay this is the
most important person in your life on
Valentine's Day even if you're not a big
Valentine's Day fan throw a little
something at them like cherries berries
and they're gonna be stoked because they
see that you went out of your way
freshly dipped strawberries from
sharri's berry starting at just $19.99
plus shipping or you can double up the
berries for just $10 more go to berries
calm and use our code CREB help support
our show by supporting our sponsors use
our code crap I do it every year for
Cape because we either the only time
we're getting sweets is when we're out
we're not like grabbin M&MS at the store
anything like that what
by the way M&Ms wouldn't even compare to
with these monster strawberries huge
strawberry berries they're decadent
fresh juicy sweet shareable and
irresistible and let me tell you
something anytime you see something like
seen in a movie or a TV show when people
about to get on TV it's a strawberry
dipped chocolate go for it these are
dipped in tempting white milk dark
chocolate goodness they're covered with
like swizzles or chopped nuts or
chocolate chips the ones that read loves
Sherry's berries will deliver your gift
fresh in on time guaranteed or your
money back you got a week so get on it
today
visit berries calm berr IES calm click
on the microphone on the top right hand
corner and type in crap that's berries
calm and use our code crab help support
our show and by supporting our sponsors
be on time y'all and if you need to be
on time movement watches his back that's
MVM t watches pronounced movement
founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank their goal is
to change the way consumers think about
fashion by offering high quality
minimalist products at revolutionary
prices MV mt watches has solidified
itself as the world's fastest growing
watch company I again I tell you guys
about my watch all the time I love it
feels good looks good I get complimented
non-stop on it people like where'd you
get that how'd you get that tell them
all time about em VMT watches it goes
good dress up goes good cash whatever
your style is the company was started by
two broke college kids that wanted to
wear stylish watches but couldn't afford
them so they started their own watch
company much like we started this own
podcast out here young a movement
watches start at just 95 dollars that's
fantastic
at a department store for this same
watch you're looking at four to five
hundred bucks movement figured out that
by selling online they were able to cut
out the middleman and retail markup
providing the best possible price it's a
classic design quality construction and
style minimalism over five hundred
thousand watches sold already in over
160 countries which is insane get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mV mt watches
dot-com / Crabb that's M
VMT watches dot-com / crab VMT watches
can also be a perfect gift for your
Valentine this watch has a really clean
design I'm not lying - I've been getting
compliments ever since I put it on now
is the time to step up your watch game
go to mV mt watches dot-com / crab and
join the movement and gentlemen well it
doesn't have to be just gentlemen but
mostly aren't you tired of guessing what
she wants for Valentine's Day ladies
you're probably tired of guessing what
he wants - wouldn't you love an easy
fail-proof way to look like a pro this
year ProFlowers is making it easier than
ever by taking all of the guesswork out
on top of their already low prices right
now you can get two dozen assorted roses
with a free glass vase for $29.99 plus
shipping and handling or upgrade and for
$9.99 more you can get two dozen
long-stem assorted roses with premium
vase and chocolate just go to
proflowers.com use our code crab help
support our show by supporting our
sponsors use our code crab you can pick
your flowers you'll be checked out in
two minutes
alright we get them every year every
year they look fantastic they come fresh
they blossom in front of your eyes you
take care of them
they're guaranteed the last seven days
look at them open up but I'm telling you
they last longer than that if you follow
the instructions and do what they say
it's also a great gift if mother-in-law
aunt uncle you start dating daughter
what about it - parent I mean it's a
no-brainer it doesn't have to be your
wife or girlfriend
everyone loves boyfriend or husband
you can set the delivery day you want
you can order now and have it delivered
on Valentine's Day right to home or work
when her co-workers gush over her gift
you'll know you did to Valentine's Day
right ProFlowers bouquets are guaranteed
to last seven days or your money back
you can't beat the price and convenience
ProFlowers takes care of the details you
get to just sit back and look awesome
when I send flowers
I trust / flowers to get it right here's
the only way to get two dozen assorted
roses with a free glass vase starting at
just $29.99 go to proflowers.com use our
code crab that's proflowers.com help
support our show by
supporting our sponsors click on the
microphone and type in our code crab
don't wait order today this deal expires
soon
ladies and gentlemen excited to have on
for the first time long term friends we
love him to death please welcome Bobby
Lee Oh fine I'm so glad to be here with
thick Jay Larson and chubby cheeks ride
sick thanks sick cooler that's your name
Ryan Sickler know the way you accent
guitar that's how you say first time I
met you dude is that [ __ ] thing we
just did out like a month ago right your
energy was all over the place yeah I
loved it yeah yeah very Hollywood thank
you yeah and you man I've known you for
how long man I met you 14 years ago 14
[ __ ] years and I got it on video
yeah I know I do I just remember you've
always been a part of my life
I have an interview Bob never not with
you in the kitchen at Dublin's all [ __ ]
remember that yeah I remember those are
the good old days huh those are the good
old day when you living above the comedy
store uh yeah and Paul used to UM Paulie
was the landlord he was you also was in
there when you were there myself
oh really a nightmare this is Bobby Lee
the greatest thing you beat the economy
store Sunday nights and Bobby Lee would
just be standing the corner of smoke and
saying I'm like we're doing it like add
the guys from MADtv they've been the
writers are dropping off the script for
the week I'm just waiting for him I was
just like oh my god amazing life really
because I was suicidal that never you're
never happy with what you have you know
you're in a situation you're like oh my
god this is great but it's not in your
head you always want more as a human
being it's what I've done over the years
is I pretended you know what I've done
as I live in the moment and I'm happy
for what I have it's really changed
everything guys I know you also you're
the one who introduced me like I didn't
know Kevin Kristy was ever like did art
but you have like the more I have a
Kevin Christi original in my house yeah
and you got like six or seven Kevin
Christian yeah I love that guy
I gotta stand up you did yeah how I did
a commercial of am/pm commercial with a
guy named Kevin Durant I don't feel
Kevin Durant but Kevin Durant was into
[ __ ] Gold's they warrior
soccer player no what is he I thought
you said Kevin Durant Duran let me see
if I get the right name hold on
Durant Kevin am I already [ __ ] up the
thing yep Duran when you did this
commercial Kevin Durant was probably
middle school really yeah yeah no his
name is this guy kevin durand is an
actor he was in lost a bunch of [ __ ] oh
yeah okay anyway we didn't a.m.
commercial and am/pm commercial and
kevin Christie was a skinny white kid
nerd and he was the lead in the
commercial I was angry about it but
anyway became friends and then when who
did you play in the commercial we run
his friend in it oh okay you weren't in
there at the am/pm anyway that's your
laugh I love it Bobby's reaction to
price you get no [ __ ] I get up no I'm
kidding thanks for having me on guys oh
oh yeah thanks for being here so before
we start getting deeper into this plug
your social media Bobby Lee live we're
here for the we're here for the
comedians have any other pie yes do you
plug your [ __ ] up top
who had Bobby Lee what I mean why'd you
get Bobby Lee live somebody else had
Bobby Lee I know who I don't know
there's actually a slide guitarist named
Bobby Lee that's cool Texas or something
any good all the photos like the first
50 photos is me yeah kill it Cuddy yeah
and I'm a [ __ ] fat [ __ ] yeah
too much for you little much have you
ever used that word [ __ ] just talking
about you in the way here about your
family
you're very fast thanks yeah but social
media Wow Bobby Lee live Twitter
Instagram my podcast is called tiger
belly we're under in the same family
it's called um Paul what's it called all
thing comedy yeah all things calm and
then um that's it
I'm on the second season of love
starting in March oh that's dough that's
great just five episodes fine
oh well we back up you know I mean I had
a great run in the 90s many years that
I've done it and it's a constant
constant work right yeah yeah yeah so
that's in your [ __ ] face yeah no
that's right why cuz you hang out with
David Lynch now I mean we just we
meditate together once okay get your
head has gotten really crazy did your
tone was this like you know mean you're
not working as much because you're on
top is that what your thing is now I'm
not on top at all I green literally did
four scenes
oh yeah yeah I did it but let me tell
you something right now you have no idea
that because I'm a huge Lynch I mean
raise your head from Elephant Man 2
everybody I love them and if you're a
fan like me four scenes is the world
yeah no I had some friends who were like
big-time actors and I told him I'm like
oh I'm doing they're like are you
[ __ ] serious is Lynch direct I'm like
yeah they're like oh my god dude I know
and I I was like so nervous on set my I
said I text my buddy I'm like hey man
I'm just hanging in the trailer should I
go to location he goes if I was there
I'd be standing in v-love village living
everything I could from David Lynch I
was like no I wouldn't yeah I didn't I
would be mystery you mean like my
dressing room yeah where is he show up a
little a right not know your lines at
all like that I was too so afraid to not
know like even rehearsal yellow line
hello I don't care I don't know besides
you mean because you don't mean then
he'll think you're like cool doesn't
give an F all right so um
what are you running the show you wanted
to drive the bus go I know but what I'm
saying is is that how does it work now I
tell stories well we like talk about
some stuff like groan I mean especially
I mean if people know your stand-up I'm
sure many of you don't cuz it's very old
like older you know I mean it was a long
time ago not current we're 25 because
that was like an 80s slam that's what
the 80s used to do yeah like a lot of
those comics go hey you're like a
glorified future whatever it's like I
make more money than you have you know
way more but no I mean I remember when I
first started Dublin's you were just
murdering how great was that room roof
the great is a night yeah Dublin's too
these he would get more people in that
room then the Comedy Store would get all
weekend yeah
on a Tuesday you would walk off stage
and just business cards three arts real
stingray I'm not kidding you
and then like I met Cameron Diaz's
Timberlake used to go Britney Spears and
they're all there to see Dane yeah right
but if you could get on that show my god
and I got one really that's when I was
early on starting I got one show there
it was fan [ __ ] test right hacked all
the way to the back yeah everyone in
good spirits you know like that was they
were there to see the show was RIT was a
[ __ ] great show do you ever do
Miyagi's across the street yeah yeah I
was there right and I did a show and
this blonde beautiful I can't say her
name but um beautiful she was stuck at
she was 18 she snuck in and she's a her
pair of parents huge MADtv fans uh-huh
she just kind of looks at me cross-eyed
and she goes oh my god she was so cute
and she goes hey you wanna [ __ ] whoa so
I go yeah well can you come just to my
parent parents house she lived with her
parents
where where'd you have to go it wasn't
like wait so you know did her parents
know that she was taking you home to
bone I don't know but I went yeah so
it's like 11:00 at night she had to wake
them up I'm not [ __ ] kidding you I go
in there and it's just one of those like
you know like you know you know who I
love Steven Spielberg because Steven
Spielberg he always liked Annie tee
he always did like suburban family home
in the most realistic we knew that you
did and we we went out of our way for
this one you know gonna believe this hi
that's a would say if it Steven
Spielberg was here effeminately I have
to hunger out here I think that ET house
is out and talking about here really I
love that suburban [ __ ] is that how you
grow up this is the story or not
trying to help you out [ __ ] it we're
gonna be dancing that's all time anyway
so um I meet her parents they were
sleeping you know can I get dirty or no
ya ever you want so we go to her room
right and she's got like you know like
Backstreet Boy like posters on the wall
said please tell me there's a man TV
poster no no no we didn't have
phosphorous so you creep by her parents
bedroom mother sleeping no they came out
and he gave me a hard I took photos and
stuff wait well he had their fans so it
photos there I literally went into her
room right so they knew she was on her
belly right and I just you know I you
know I did it yeah and I just left and I
remember going I remember crying why
because you have to understand that in
God created me mm-hmm
to go out with and three foot four girl
named Tingting he doesn't let me develop
fat asian kids and goes you're gonna
kill it you guys know you're with ting
ting I got ting ting she's a Vietnam she
runs a phone you know I mean restaurant
whatever and that's what you're gonna do
but you know what I defy God he sure did
and I said nah [ __ ] ting ting yeah I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go all the way right
so if you look in the mirror I always
looked at the mirror and saw Brad Pitt
even though I look like you know Miyagi
Miyagi Marina that marina I see it now
Thank You Monsignor wait do you think
the Rita in happy days yeah absolutely
on Arnold's working back there do you
think a lot of chicks love just like
you're the fantasy of hooking up with a
asian dude well I mean every white chick
that I ever dated though if you went if
you go to their house eventually you
know that they have the fetish there's
like nunchucks and enter the Great
Dragon like they're dogs
so you go oh you're one of those but
they're all like that yeah and they
always tell stories like yeah in the 70s
like my dad used to take me
Kung Fu I'm like Film Festival's and
you're like that's what you got oh
that's where it is yeah but anyway yeah
that's you know but you're not matter
what I mean like you know mad about them
my whole thing is just to like take what
you have and go all the way with it it's
a really good message is it not it is a
good message I thought wait so you but
you grew up down in San Diego and and
was an amazing
was it suburban like you loved he didn't
like it at it why because it's a
military town really and very
conservative and I was virtually
unfuckable yeah I mean I would like were
you [ __ ] hilarious though and I know
I would know of this guy named Matt you
ADA some Japanese dude Matt you wait I
got funniest kid in class wherever and
it's in the yearbook but you knew you
were funny I mean I I'm funnier than
every single one of them combined but
they didn't see it yeah because I I lack
social skills in that way do you think
you still do I do it 100% mm-hmm
even Patrice O'Neal once told me um that
you're never gonna do as well as Ken
Jeong or any of these other guys and I
go why and he said because you're like
me and you go to a party and you don't
know what the [ __ ] to do
yeah you sit in the back you leave early
you don't talk to anybody and you don't
have that skill you're hilarious that's
what he said but I'm like and I agree
with them I just can't do it yeah no I
hear it man I feel like don't you feel
like a lot of comedians have social
anxiety where they don't or just don't
know how to interact yeah but some of
those guys of course some of those guys
can do it and it's those guys that kill
it yeah they go all the way they can do
both you know for some reason is I'm
just one of those guys that can yeah and
then I'm perceived in being an [ __ ]
or whatever or he's like he doesn't want
to play but it's like I just don't know
what to say and I don't know what to do
you know and it I was just always been
like that yeah you know I can't I don't
have the game in that way I can go up
onstage I can audition I can memorize my
lines and show
up and do the best I can in that way and
I walk through those kind of fears which
is like that's all I care about
yeah well to be brave I'm pretty good so
far I mean you have to we all have you
know me and we're uh we're dream weavers
and that's a fact that's a fact
your eyes are so good that's what was
your first job when you were growing up
as a kid oh man I had a lot of bad ones
but um I worked for Del Taco for a week
yeah because I was uh yeah I was uh 16 I
don't know if you guys know this but out
to three rehabs by the time I was 17
years old whoa-ohh for what for
marijuana drinking meth acid you know
just the standard sentence mess yeah by
the time you were 17 yeah so how old
were you the first time in 15 Wow
yeah yeah and how long at that point had
you been doing drugs like 12 real of 13
you how'd you get introduced my dad my
dad's an alcoholic and he had a
refrigerator in the garage and um my mom
used to stock it but my drinks my dad
drank so much that she was just always
stalking it so if I took five beers a
night it's still she wouldn't didn't no
one noticed at 12 you were drinking five
beers a night yeah one lasted at eight
so I was let's just go through my life
yeah all right well I should at 8 then I
sucked a couple of penises that were my
choice it at 12 I started drinking and
then 13 I started smoking pot and that's
acid and then 14 math and then from then
on how are you doing at school when
you're going all left really mm-hmm
so you weren't doing anything I mean I
played I was on the tennis team and I
was on the wrestling team you wrestled
yeah oh my I was pretty good too were
you the lightweight no yes I'm like five
for now but we have a smaller kid than
you is lightweight really yeah like he
wasn't even a hundred pounds he was like
89 and 90
pal how old was he then like 14 I feed
him just get there my [ __ ] kid
I wasn't your kid no oh you're saying
when you grew up in I see yeah yeah yeah
there was this guy named Tony matushi
and he had a mustache this is
unbelievable he still hasn't he was
literally like look like our sorcerer
like he was like 5 1
he was like borderline [ __ ] or
something but he was very good but
anyway my point is is this but I got I
went to three rehab so did you have
therapy anywhere in here and did you
tell your parents what I wanted your
parents know you were molested no well
the one time I told them the first time
I told them is I was at the oceanview
Recovery Center it's an oceanside and
great facility great great great great
view proud sponsor the craft yeah they
have pool table the ping-pong table and
but they used to do this thing called um
needs to knees so what it was was um
you're in a room with everyone's family
so that's made me I imagine like 16 kids
and their parents are there and
grandparents and family so you're not
kind of an auditorium they form a circle
and in the center of the circle are two
chairs so you sit there with your like
dad or your mom and you touch knees and
they you tell them and everyone else can
hear yeah everyone's alright it's weird
very have anxiety right now right so I'm
about sixteen or whatever and I'm
sitting there and my dad's there right
and my dad's an alcoholic my dad's also
like just an old-school working-class
Korean he's like no I don't want to pay
for whatever so I go so dad when I was
eight nine I am wasn't molested by a guy
with Down syndrome and there's a pause
in the room and then my but this is what
my dad did he would you laugh no yeah
yeah yeah and then my brother started
laughing then my mom sort of laughing no
yeah and then I started laughing
and then the whole room started laughing
so you Russian heroes killing it
killing it early and then it took it
away
what do you mean it took her the pain of
it it became funny to me Jesus it was it
was it could have been better
you know you look at a bad situation
like that and the [ __ ] that I did I mean
that was experienced but it turned it I
looked at it in a funny way was like oh
you know I don't die I don't have AIDS
I'm fine you know and so I think that's
when it started my humor how many more
times you in rehab after that a couple
more times so clearly it didn't
completely heal well statistically it's
only what five percent recovery is that
really what it is that's it yes you know
I uh you've been clean and sober for I
thought was 15 but fourteen yeah and
then twelve years before that so when I
was 17 to 29 I was sober relapsed and
then I got in 14 again forty five or two
years Wow cuz when you get sober that
young there is a thing where you go
maybe it was just a phase yeah and then
when you're actually doing it again
you're like no it wasn't oh yeah I'm
like I am a drug addict it's the way I
do it yeah I go all the way yeah I mean
and so becoming smiling when I say stuff
like that because I'm trying to find the
humor in there really no it's real
honestly I'm still laughing about you
getting molested yeah but anyway it's
deep alright so you said you're gonna go
through your life so you go through
three rehabs yeah and then what and then
17 you're clean and sober right and then
I am no no I said mom until I was 20 are
you doing stand-up at this point no I
was um you worked at The Comedy Store
lawyer though right yeah but I'm gonna
get to that it's not there I just want
to lead you cuz honestly there's like a
little bit of a look in your face like
I'm not really sure what to say I know
exactly what they just want to make sure
you know where you're going I know it's
my life you know you can't just say this
and I'm going to say this yeah good your
[ __ ] challenge
either way where I've never been
challenged before let me just say this
okay I'm a [ __ ] professional okay I
know my [ __ ] life right I don't know
when to be real and not to be real and
what you're doing right now is you're
throwing me off I just understand that
pen fifteen minutes late so I just
wanted I don't know how professional you
are yeah I don't know why it's so far
away from where I live I'm sorry where'd
you live I live in Hollywood
and who lives out here you do and
everybody else not really everyone lives
in Hollywood everyone come on okay so
anyway I'm 17 and so I made living you
guys want no living amends is um I know
a little bit about it but what I did was
I stayed at home a graduate from high
school and I spent three years making
amends to my parents for like all the
bad [ __ ] I did I stole money from them I
hit my mom in the face a bunch of time
well my dad bought you time oh yeah yeah
was like open-handed or yeah yes I hated
her
well I thought I hated her going on you
have a lot of issues going on so when I
got sober I asked you in a quick quick
question yeah was this this amends thing
is this a personal thing or just through
the program or like what it was a
personal thing where I thought you know
my thoughts are still in high school I'm
not going to college because got aw
laughs I barely graduated even though I
was sober and I wanted to like so I work
for my parents well you know I did stuff
around the house my parents owned a
clothing store a clothing store but you
would do you make amends by staying home
by being a good dude you know me clean
the house being a good kid and going to
a lot of meetings and you know and then
my parents moved to Phoenix and when I
was 20 and I moved out and I lived in La
Jolla legit Allah who do you live with
by myself and then I met a couple of
guys from the program I lived with them
and then I just worked at coffee shops
and construction and restaurants bar
backpacking house connection yeah why
did you like it not my friend Dan his
dad was a he owned like a cattle company
like in the Midwest or whatever so it
was rich huh so they were building a
house and he they hired me to get be
like to Aaron so I would go to
are you having because he's selling
construction he's a Rob he's a runner
but he's selling his construction but it
was a construction company right so
runner offshoot from the cattle company
yeah you know you know what I got this
new job in broadcasting that I've been
working on it's called the Kraft he's
man I get it guys start over then I'll
just say I was I was a delivery boy I
feel better no I'm still no just it's
more accurate but it doesn't feel better
but it can tell you what happened so
some working these jobs in San Diego I
have no future okay I took some improv
classes from Gary Austin do you know who
that is
in 1971 Gary Gary stole life but he
started The Groundlings in 1971 whoa
good growlings for a while he started if
you look at The Groundlings building
there's a plaque with his name on it in
the front
sounds very legend but wait you were
taking classroom in San Diego yeah he
would come down into these classes and
then um it's so weird then I took the
ones in LA and it is so [ __ ] weird
this actually happened so we were at
Jerry's deli in North Hollywood and I'm
I don't know 21 22 years old and we're
sitting there and Gary Austin goes what
else do you do when I go I play the
piano because I never knew you'd play
the piano
I don't I do he's like why don't you say
those things you know the things that
you know how to do or things that you
and I get shy you guys know you're gonna
tell the whole restaurant you play the
piano
sure what he's like yeah what are you in
ten years if you do this right now in
ten years you'll do Lantau you'll be on
Leno so I stood up and I yelled I'd play
the piano and then the default jerry's
restaurant they applauded uh-huh and
then a guy will not appear
ten years later I did Leno really really
yeah that's great
so dude that's so cool really cool story
huh so wait where did you learn piano
along the way when I was a kid anyway
that's another to do with my
[ __ ] story my life is this how the
show's supposed to go or no no structure
but tell me how the show was supposed to
go
I love whatever this is yeah I'm just
gonna do it this way Bruce Lee says be
like water we're just gonna be like how
he does it
wait where did you learn piano all Asian
kids have to relearn an instrument
growing up I mean well same in my family
we're all white but we have another
learnings but you can really play like
well yeah okay why didn't you
incorporate that into the show I don't
want to do it thanking you never do like
a VM did your show dude was so
petrifying every element of it I was
scared yeah I regret it almost when I
did that first rehearsal she tried to
get out of it I did try I talked her
into it you know do you heard what I
said would you say I said they had a
horn section here just wait no no that's
right they did did you kill that I know
killed it but once I accepted it that
you have to do you signed a contract
yeah did I did I did it yeah but anyway
do you do that a lot with things like
commit to it because you know that if
you're committed you'll make yourself do
it
I do that lot with auditions where I
don't go like I'll show up now I won't
go in really yeah you'll leave yeah I've
done that like 20 times in my life
Wow and it's such a bad thing because
it's like I've walked out of auditions
not even I walked into your room didn't
do it and just left what do you say
never mind no I'll just leave a Larry
dude really and your agent calls and
goes what the [ __ ] happened yeah and
they get really mad and so a lot of
reason why I don't get a lot of things
is because of that behavior that I used
to do yeah but now I show up to every
single one of them yeah you know because
you're not gonna work you know for sure
because I always thought no she's just
good at all four yeah right but that's
not how the world works
no I mean even I know people have gotten
like huge and then like you know you're
a saw Evan flows you know yeah yeah yeah
I have to go in and you have to try but
anyway what happened was I was - here's
what happened I was living in La Jolla
but there was this place city called
Pacific Beach right by local TV very
grace to be a place called the Olano
Club and what it is is it's just a
24-hour Clubhouse for people in a
readings 24 hours a day you know yeah
and so I was skateboarding past the alot
of club and I saw dudes sitting there
with like 30 years sobriety playing like
card games and chess they're just there
all day and I thought to myself I'm not
gonna get sober you know and like just
do that I don't want that out of my life
I wanna I want something more yeah right
so you know I prayed about a little bit
and then the guy was working at a coffee
shop called the dis cafe and one day I
showed up and was completely closed
okay it said we're just not where do
they tell you no there's no cell phones
back then yeah so they didn't didn't
tell me I just showed up to work and
we're closed forever but right next to
disc a face it go just fired
I know the comedy store was next to it
okay in La Jolla yeah so I went next
door and there to help want a sign and I
go home I knocked on the door during the
day and this guy Fred burns answer an
eagle a lot okay I worked in remember I
used to get change I will get this cafe
oh yeah
what I got ya you doesn't help wanna say
yeah what yeah what are you want a job
and yeah you can wash dishes I got wash
dishes so I got that job bar back well
yeah
oh yeah and then two weeks in I bar
backed the open mind on a Sunday and
that's when I knew I was gonna do
stand-up did you do it that night no it
took me a couple weeks but I did it
because not scary with that night not
really because never think you're gonna
make it you never think it's gonna be
like in the beginning of Psych I'll just
try it and then one night I got it was
so lucky like six months in I was doing
it maybe three times a week and Pauly
Shore was there I'd opened that he was
there with like two blonds
he was drunk and this is when he was
like this is in 1995 oh man so this is
when he was like kinda peeking he was
still doing movies and he guess he saw
me at open mic I was like a lot late and
he goes did you find he'd you know I'm
like what he's like yeah open for me
dude right I've been doing a column six
seven months oh man love you like I'd
love to my just cannot go these dishes
yeah yeah and then two months later I
was in Vegas oh so he must been do 5,000
6,000 seats to show right at the top of
the roof and how long you doing five
minutes just fine yeah but he wanted me
and then wild wooly Parsons mm-hmm and
then him and I only had five minutes you
know how in the beginning he didn't
weigh if I Boris yeah and Mitzi was
there his mom and I remember her coming
out you guys yeah
suck it up and then if steve Schirripa
was there you know Steve Troy yeah no I
know
you know Steve but he was on Sopranos
yeah but before he was the talent
coordinator for the Riviera oh wow
it was a the big dude yeah hey if you do
more than five you're dead if you do
before five you're dead you five so I go
up there and oh my god and I did really
good at the first show and then Mitzi
comes up to me and she goes you're a
regular Wow that's why I'm doing nine
months into comedy and she made me a
paid regular in LA oh yeah awesome
literally I moved to LA well everyone in
San Diego hated me of course all the
doormen nail and all the other comics
they had a mingle [ __ ] you know what you
go you guys go [ __ ] yourselves you're
Bobby you became a right dudes working
construction two months ago because it's
like when you first start off bro it's
like they don't they're not supportive
no now he'll know there's dude with
people that's why I'm sorry why there's
no union I'm not bragging because I'm a
piece of [ __ ]
okay but I have let's Shaffir Mike black
all these guys I got them [ __ ]
commercial agents yeah all right I got
got you know I try to help people get
understand I do what I can to help
people right yeah piece of shits down
there nothing
yeah and the dead fan started doing it
do you realize so I earlier you when I
was so the first time I did stand-ups
was was at Dublin's Wow then I used to
run around there all the time because I
was like oh this is where I could get
stage time and I started my buddy who
was like wanted to be a cinematographers
like maybe I could start filming you all
time like he'd like we filmed my first
set all my stand-up and then we would
bring the camera doubles and try and
interview comedians and we interviewed
you in the kitchen downstairs of
Dublin's and like first you like classic
Bobby Lee your
just [ __ ] with us and then you go
into this amazing you gave me this like
heartfelt speech and you go like we're
talking about like I asked you like how
do you get a manager and Bobby Lee goes
you don't don't go looking for a manager
you know why and I go no and he goes cuz
you're like a coffee bean okay you're a
product you're a coffee bean the better
the coffee bean people will come find it
they're not gonna go to you just cuz
your coffee bean you have to be a really
good coffee bean and then people didn't
use you to make coffee so you just may
said like just get better at stand-up
and they'll come to you and I was like I
still believe that that's right I get
dig up that tape I got it I still
believe that I don't remember saying
that but I do believe that I believe
that because you know when you first
come to LA people are like I almost have
my sag card yeah that means yeah it
doesn't mean anything I can got that
after one or not just outlasted them
till they became but I'm there yeah you
look to your left I'll be there we're
headshots I get on your way though yeah
I got a good head shot you mean it's
like wow yeah people still use old ass
headshots anyway it's completely bored
don't get them yeah yeah yeah don't get
them I don't even use one yeah yeah so
it's like and then one day people will
just go like that's what happened to me
when I was I did Leno is I was at I was
working the door at the Comedy Store in
the back door and Bob and I wait how is
that possible ten years in the comedy
you still were no not ten years okay I
used five years in the comedy and then
you did Leno yeah stand-up but that was
five years when I said ah - Gary Austin
that was five years before you know me
if you bro add them all up it was ten
years yeah yeah nine years maybe [ __ ]
anyway was that your first late-night
set no I had done well yeah I mean I had
done premium blend okay so you were on
the original premium blend yeah yeah but
then they came up to me goes I go I work
the door that ya know but we would think
who you can do it and then they just
kept watching me you know see I got on
but my point is is that I didn't ask to
do it I mean they just if you can do it
they're gonna they need to fill their
shows with somebody right so it's like
it's not gonna be a
so who what's needy yeah look at me look
at me look at me no you want to be the
guy like who's that guy oh he doesn't
say I didn't know buddy but he's good
you know on say stage and you know he's
also ethnic yeah we've never you know
the last time Margaret did it eight
years ago we got to put an ethnic guy on
yeah let's just put him on wait there
was no Asian comedian between Margaret
Cho and Henry Rose before that no no
there wasn't a lot of there was I can
name him I mean there was to my yacht
Sookie what I mean there's no way to my
oh sorry
he's outside the window she's coming up
he was uh my time so now okay Henry
Henry Cho Henry Cho to my Johnny Yoon
that was in the early eighties do it who
also has a great ukulele album this is
how easy agent Comics had it in the 80s
Johnny UHN right he did a series of
movies called they call me Bruce yeah
okay so Johnny Yoon was a stand-up you
wear a tuxedo anyone go in front of a
packed room at in the original room at
The Comedy Store uh-huh his opening the
line used to get a two-minute applause
break come on this is what he would do I
swear to God he would go up on stage
smile and he would go like this he go
at all two minute plus break nah two
minutes that's all he would say crush at
all because to them they were like oh my
god he doesn't notice a Hello used to
our you know mean yeah he you know he
didn't say anything right away he would
wait 20 seconds so there's a little
tension and he was very super subtle
super subtle yeah and then that would
crush and what were you were you working
the door at this time no in the 80s no
oh yeah yeah no he was way before my
time yeah yeah but I you know I always
like you know I I knew what was before
me yeah but the only the person that
like was legitimately the person that
get is Margaret
because Margaret was um knowing she was
Korean she was also know accent yeah she
talked about things that were like her
American experience of just being she
was a regular girl yeah and it's like
that's like tomorrow Otsuki still had an
accent right and she walked kimono
onstage so was this like I don't want to
do that that's on me yeah yeah I was at
an audition the other day and there was
another audition happening and they're
just Asian dudes pouring in
yeah and there's like one dude I see a
guy leave just wearing like khakis and a
shirt yeah right yeah and then I see
this dude come in he's got like a duffel
bag and I'm like alright this guy's just
doing his thing yeah and then this other
dude comes in with his like mom or
grandmother yeah
who's like struggling she's like a
walker and she sits down next to me
she's auditioning I am and she's so cute
and then the woman comes out and gets
the guy with a duffel bag and she's like
oh you ready to go and he pulls out this
whole like karate uniform he's like yeah
gene goes now I gotta I gotta get
changed the other guy's like yeah I can
go like I'm like blood change and had a
sword with a man nunchucks one was a
white girlfriend is that does that
disappoint you didn't think that holds
you guys back it's had you sit with two
hands over your face it's just years of
like that [ __ ] of getting [ __ ] like
that
yeah you know like I've been there
whereas like you know you're you're a
black belt in karate
and I'd call me I don't know Quran it
will just show up improvise and then you
show up and there's ninjas like
full-blown ninjas thick in the room
there's not the wall outside there's no
lines right - yeah obviously it's they
want to see how good you're at karate
and then I walk in you know karate
no all right sigh can you rappel from
the ceiling right now so wait yeah can
you run on the rooftops you had early
success in standup but as far as acting
goes was there a lot a long time of like
auditioning and going through [ __ ]
and all that I mean in the beginning was
like that but then I went like I called
well my agent like my commercial agent
at the time was Lawrence horror who was
a Korean dude mm-hmm and I was at Abrams
artists and I go do just send me out on
white [ __ ] commercials and he goes I'll
try so there was just one where they
wanted um a brad pitt looking guy
log-cabin he had a log cabin it was a
Maxwell House commercial uh-huh so
basically there's no lines buts a guy
you know with a ax you know I mean he's
got white kind of you know
salt-and-pepper hair good-looking white
dude and he's drinking coffee I know in
the lodge yeah and then looking your
resume like says he did construction
right so I show max right and I show up
it's all 50 year old forty year old
really good-looking white dudes you know
I mean wearing like you know did the
look yeah and I got it did you really
yep I'm gonna get this because whenever
it's this when there's no lines and they
go we're just gonna ask you questions
whenever that's the audition I got it
because your reaction I ever amazing no
I know yeah what'd you do for Halloween
and then boom I'm gonna make everyone
laugh Yeah right and I'm gonna get it
you know III look at all these comics
and I go I I look at him I go you
literally can get almost every single
commercial if you're a stand-up yeah
and they go no no I don't even get
callback it's because it's your head
but every comic has we have muscles yeah
I'm not a good Impressionists that's why
when I was on a sketch show I was just
like why the [ __ ] am I on a sketch show
but I showed them what I can do was more
energy physical you know
well the commitment or what Christ
Connie Chung nobody yeah but I'm not
good at it at an audition with Connie
Chung I said can you try to do it and
I'll do the best I can
yeah but there's nothing wrong with
getting a job and then evolving into
other things I mean that that's what I'm
saying but what I'm saying is that I
feel like every comic has the muscle to
get pretty much every job they can win
for but they just live in their head
about it
I agree do you agree yeah make sense
yeah like like the reason why I know
Eric Stonestreet well well because him
and I did a bunch of commercials
together in the late 90s and the
callbacks were always me Kevin Kristy
Eric Stonestreet these guys that you
would just see all the time yeah because
they were all the callback eyes and we
all knew that oh it's gonna be between
me and these five or six other guys yeah
you know and it's like you have to
believe that so when I in in when I got
right before I got mad TV and right
between Tonight Show met TV in that area
I went out for an IBM commercial it was
a campaign I remember the one yeah and
they don't got it what and Kevin got it
no okay I did a bunch of IBM once okay I
remember him I did a bunch there was
three of ya and it was it was a $350,000
buyout oh damn so imagine being a
doorman that's when I quit during the
door you have like [ __ ] I'm not doing
this right I don't have a car like I
remember taking the bus to get to the
audition oh right and as soon as I did
the job and when I got a car I got a new
place you know I mean but yeah I mean I
but I oh so the thing is is that I
refused to go out on those we need a
Chinese guy who has a thick accent you
know he's at a liquor store yeah I don't
know give me the stuff that white dudes
are doing and I wouldn't get in those
rooms right away
in fact one out of every 20 but
if I did have the opportunity I would do
everything I can to [ __ ] get it
see this is bliss I mean at this is
inspiring but the same times annoying
because when I was going on for
commercials all time yeah I would say
only send me out for the Asian [ __ ] you
John Cho it's just yeah but now you know
it there you go in and it's there's
heavy weight Asian dudes yeah I mean
there's like I go in I want to leave
because I'm like there's just no when I
get there like Steven Yeun from Walking
Dead yeah that audition with him a
couple things and we talking to LA me
and I literally turned on when I go he's
friends with me and my brother and stuff
and I always turned oh my gosh and leave
because it's like he's good-looking he's
way more talented he's a nice guy you
know and it's so I loved seeing like
someone like Ali Wong and Steven Yeun
and some of these guys these this next
generation of like getting just they
have like morals and values that are
like that we didn't even have right I
got to want to do that because it's too
you know mean ethnic whereas me is like
yeah I'll do it if it's a light accent
right all right so it's like um yeah
it's really kind of cool in that way
yeah you know I didn't know that this
was gonna be like like I thought you
guys said just do a story what are you
talking about what do you think it is
like you called me last week and you
were like
you just get a story run it by me I'll
give you notes or something like that
I'm like this I said we usually ask not
usually we ask everybody to come a four
or five of their favorite stories to
tell yeah I have a lot of stories all
right let's talk about them which ones
what do you love the town actually what
do you think of some of your funniest
stories that you love to tell I mean I
have a lot
I mean these are stories I've told
before though on podcast not to this
audience that is true you have a
specific audience yeah I can talk about
um I already did that on Comedy Central
no let me think um because all that
thing that Ari Shaffir does well that's
oh yeah this is not happening not
happening yeah yeah but still we weren't
there we're worried when you did it I
mean I have one story that I'm reluctant
to tell that I've never told because
it's really [ __ ] up and I feel like
people are gonna judge me well no one's
judging you hear that no I want to say
it this story right here is so [ __ ]
creepy on my part and also I might be
illegal okay I'm at people to do the
story without saying the implications of
you know what am I don't say names and
don't say implications yeah but if you
really think you shouldn't say it don't
[ __ ] say it you know what I'm gonna
change the story a bit but I'll give you
this you know man yeah have you ever
told it before
no I I mean I've tried to but then I've
stopped because I got I can't talk I'll
tell it okay alright okay before I tell
the story though I want to say this okay
I have to do yeah delay things down in
ground and go ahead lay it all out okay
so I'm sweating now
number one I've been sober for 14 years
okay number two I in love with my
girlfriend I had I did the podcast with
her a tiger belly I've been dating her
for three and a half years I've never
cheated on any girlfriend
and I've had sexual problems before and
this is in the heyday of my sexual
problems and also secondly this is the
element the real element of why I
started doing stand-up cool
okay now you you're not clean and sober
during this period I am you know I'm
also dry drunk which what does that mean
when you don't go to meetings anymore
and then all of a sudden your behavior
is like an alcoholic but you're not
drinking that so your behavior you know
and also I just also want to say this is
that be before the age of 23
couldn't get girls yeah at all I mean I
was San Diego I was virtually unfuckable
I tried nobody liked me I had no
confidence so during that time I went
used to go to brothels okay really yeah
brah did you take a [ __ ] will cover
what Adelita it was in Tijuana so it was
much like Deadwood I mean it's it's the
Old West back then yeah and you were
clearly probably still having effects
from all the stuff he went there as a
kid don't you think yeah okay yeah so um
so how old are you 17
no I was this is like maybe almost when
I was 23
alright okay and I used to work at this
restaurant I can't name what it's a
great restaurant the [ __ ] that's
nothing to do with the restaurant but
the restaurants called the Brockton
Villa it's the best restaurant in La
Jolla is still there and make the leaves
the owner and she's the [ __ ] best
okay okay but on Wednesday nights the
guy the waiters after we waited tables
we used to go to take our tip money and
go to Tijuana Tijuana so one night none
of the guys could go right so I'll go by
myself and I go to hahaha I go and this
is a [ __ ] crazy story I go and um I
go to the Adelita and it's like all
these Marines you know there's like no
girls there so
across the street I went to this place
called the Chicago club no girls it was
just all these Marines and military
people I had never seen it that way so
there was really no girls around so what
I did was Jesus Christ I really can't
get it yeah yeah yeah so I went in back
of a delitos there's a special place
called hooker alley special place yeah
and as all the girls that can't get into
a talita wait the JV squads back back
yeah yeah oh no
what's Gav squad that's not that your
virus to the varsity yeah there are the
ugly ones the the the C team the C team
yeah right and they're just chillin in
the alley there's like yeah it's like oh
so when you walk through the alley they
grab you
oh right they grab you got an imam
khomeini parade to kind of pry them away
right and at the end so yeah at the end
of hooker alley there's a girl that
looks like Natalie Portman but like 300
pounds heavier with the face but the
face is there the vase is there yeah
it's like meet Michael Chiklis his body
right and she also you could she doesn't
want to be there you can tell that like
I don't know what happened the most
prostitutes probably don't want to be
doing right occupy so um so we go to
this at the end of this alley there's
this place called Miami hotel and it's
it's like the movie se7en it's like you
know those fly traps on the ceilings to
see I'm picturing like Cuba and like the
the sixth like the 30s or something like
that one metal fan on the desk just set
in it exactly yeah but it sounds a
little worse yeah but it's also the
ground is like adhesive oh yeah this
place just sounds sickly right like my
shoes sticks to the ground so we go to
this room they give you paid $10 and
then they give you like a towel and like
ten bucks yeah this is also 1994 guys
okay yeah I hear still
23 years ago so then I am we go in the
room and she could we get naked and I
put the condom on and it's dark
completely dark and so I start having
sexual intercourse with her mm-hmm
making love I say yeah I think you sweet
love is this can I ask you this real
quick is this your first prostitute ever
no no no I already said I say that
already though unfuckable yeah yeah I
just thought it out before this when I
got sober I started going to brothels
then oh yeah
which is I'm not proud of and but I
admit it okay always in Tijuana or any
in San Diego no because it's back there
was 40 bucks see Baltimore was always it
wasn't it wasn't it was always tanning
tanning salons
yeah open 24 that's how you knew yeah
yeah yeah that should he ever had a
brothel I've been to one time in Tijuana
yeah I actually did forth and be do you
remember that yeah and they gave me a
hotel room and I took my money and I
drove straight to Tijuana and I parked
I'm imagining like you did and walked
yeah thank God you haven't and went
deeper would you wink he didn't wink I'm
kidding he didn't wink so I'm having sex
with this girl and it's dark and the
moon light was shining through the the
window right and I hit her face the moon
light and she was crying yeah she was
crying yeah so as a gentleman and as a
good person I believe in God I did what
any guy would do is I started power
[ __ ] her Bobby like what just you
know so I want to get it over with
yeah you know so then after I finished I
mean you paid the ten bucks of the room
you know right exactly yeah yeah you're
so open your smart guy so then um I got
him I got my clothes on I laughed and I
went back home to San Diego by now so
that was the first half of the story
mm-hmm this is a two-parter the second
half is called God's revenge
he's always gonna bounce out it always
bounces out so to exciter on a Wednesday
I uh the guys at work we're like hey
let's go to Bravo I don't want to I feel
sick like oh then we won't go either but
I was really gonna go by myself because
I want to go down look around Hoecker
alley again and to find fat Natalie
Portman uh-huh so bad that yeah so I but
this but this time I went to hooker
alley and there was no one there there
was a grade or something I know there's
because at the end of it there was a
[ __ ] I'm sorry you don't call them
midgets what do you call him I think in
hooker alley it's okay redheaded no bye
no small / for real / hold on redhead
albino freckles albino [ __ ] and he was
Mexican I'll just call him extremely
unfortunate so ego a you like booze is
okay yeah you got a gang-up I know how
the booze is are oh cool like an idiot
oh cool lead me the way you know my
little magical friend put me on your
shoulders
yeah so walk about three blocks and then
there's another guy rerun to his buddy
who's like now the complete opposite six
two skinny tattoos cholo hey yeah so
like a [ __ ] these guys really get me
guys really no so I walk about 12 blocks
with these [ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus and the
farther we get are they talking to it on
its silent walking fast too and they're
like no tonight like the place that are
gonna take to me isn't gonna close or
something yeah right so there's like
three-legged dogs eventually no street
life you know tumbleweed it was like
Deadwood I swear to God yeah but the
farther we go the more fear I have it
just kind of dawns on me like this might
not turn out well
but you know you're Bix like they seem
well yeah yeah in your mind you're like
maybe they're gonna take you to
somewhere magical yeah
so then we get to this [ __ ] Street
and then there's a an alleyway and
there's a gate the gate opens and then
the little one runs through this
alleyway I'm like what the [ __ ] is he
running for and I'm kind of following
walking in this alleyway and then all of
a sudden I'm against the wall and this
other dude Latino guy number two had a
[ __ ] machete like in his leg you
probably weren't looking for a machete
from goso right and he kind of pulls it
out he sticks it to my neck you give me
a money think we're the girl how much
money you had on you at the time
probably 200 bucks all right yeah make
sense so then I um I pull out my wallet
I give it to him and then he he throws
my wallet into a puddle of [ __ ] water
and he proceeds to throw me back against
the wall and puts the machete back to my
neck and as if he's gonna kill me now
because at that point it's like he has
my money yeah
just let me go so now in my head I'm
like I look up at the heavens and I go
god I deserve this I deserve this this
is abhorrent behavior this is not good
and I deserve it but there was just on
another thought that I had it was like
God if you can get me through this I'll
never do this again and I will you know
me just start really trying to do
something with my life you know yeah so
then I hear two voices from the other
end of this alleyway and they're arguing
with the [ __ ] guy that has the knife
this machete to my neck and they're
arguing and I think they were arguing
about like give us some of that money
because this is our alleyway that I
don't I don't speak Spanish but but as
they're arguing like just gut I just
grabbed my wall I start running so he
let you go once he started well he just
kind of turns starts yelling I grab my
rent and I run and now at that moment
you gotta you gotta just act and go yeah
and they have three guys now chasing me
there's a running pop and I'm now
blindly running down the streets in
Tijuana I don't know where not even to
you want anymore you're like yeah you
want to Jason
arrived just one you really like it dogs
just [ __ ] running back steal [ __ ]
yeah yeah and they're chasing me because
at that point in my life I'm like I am
now I have no skills in terms of like
athletics I just I'm just not athletic
I have everywhere looks makes you look
athletic things - yeah I never believed
jogged before running like you're gone
from a cold stop right full sprint but
they're catching me and I run down the
stairs and I come around the bend and I
see on this corner of a red door red
awning neon lights
I'm assuming it's some sort of business
yeah and I'm walking toward a how many
blocks you think you made it back
towards from the four blocks maybe okay
yeah and as I'm walking toward this red
door it opens and like 30 African
American marines walk out of this
[ __ ] car
and it's I just opened my mouth that's
good hey guys I'm an American I'm an
American right I said that they
literally turned around to look at these
three guys and these three guys ran the
other way
that's amazed at it and then these two
black guys walked me to the border and I
never went back god damn what they asked
me what you were doing down there I kind
of said the ID lured me I mean I didn't
really get into detail about what my
situation but they were like we looking
for that Natalie Borman yeah yeah but
yeah I mean that you know that happened
and I'm not proud of that story but um
you have any other near-death
experiences no really no that's a
near-death experience cuz I would like
to share another one if you had you have
one uh I'm told online on there oh you
do I don't mind also was it Mexico
really
yeah I almost got mauled by a pickup
truck getting out of a cab really long
story short we took a cab into town into
Ensenada and Sunita
what is it down there I think Ensenada
and this guy is in a station wagon and
he busts so alright
we get this is what saved our lives
right here my life we're at the front
desk and the guy goes listen to me
it's a $15.00 cab ride into town if they
ask you for any more than that they're
ripping you off I'm like so but just
give him a 20 he's like 20 will cover
your tip no doubt so we get that's me
and two buddies of mine we get into this
station wagon this guy's cab he's got a
mirror goes all the way you know that
mirror get all people right got that my
he's got a buddy in the passenger seat
we don't know if it's a friend another
passenger family we have no idea he's
got a boom box in the way back that's
blaring pump up the volume remember that
one mommy it's dance yeah pump up the
volume I like the movie though great
movie
Christmas later blaring it he's like you
like would like to turn that [ __ ] down
little bit so I'll turn it down and he's
like I'm gonna get you there fast and he
jumps to the dirt shoulder and he hauls
ass I was like spring break all these
cars are just sitting bumper-to-bumper
and he's flying up this dirt shoulder
and we're scared as [ __ ] he's gone like
50 miles an hour 40 50 he's flying the
rhythm the ripple so when he stops he
stops also on the shoulder and he says
he goes bang thing and we're like notice
that has 20 in Spanish oh like no no no
he'd say he's like no no no we're like
keen say and we give him a 20 and I open
20 but we're telling them keen say which
is what we're doing is the guy said give
him a 20 and that'll give him a $5 tip
and that's more than enough right pay 20
plus we had a $20 bill right and if that
guy wouldn't have tried to get an extra
five bucks out of us I would be dead
because we're again we're on the
shoulder of the road so I am on the
driver's side
I throw the door open and this [ __ ]
f-150 pickup truck comes I mean right
here my one foots out yeah
and comes right here by my face and hits
the door and
door natural he's trying that the metals
pushing back so it beats down the whole
side of this guy's at me [ __ ] his truck
up [ __ ] it up and the guy makes a right
in front of us and just takes off he
never stops the [ __ ] door is bent
completely all the way up hanging off
this guy's like [ __ ] what I'm like we're
getting the [ __ ] out of here right now
I'm not getting arrested in Mexico and
we run and just blend into the crowd and
then it then it hit me I was like home I
that would have been the most brutal
death to be stuck in me to be smushed
like that is that how you got that
mutation on your hands how that happened
today I woke up like that's your [ __ ]
face leave it I wash my face every time
I thought this [ __ ] will stop in my 20s
I'm in my 40s can you guys give me a
second though I just need to do
something I want to keep going we can
just give me a second I know this is not
the way you guys do your [ __ ] but just
give me a second okay I have to lie to
somebody real quick yeah I'm supposed to
be somewhere right now do you lie a lot
I do a lie a lie but I'm going to just
call somebody real quick okay can we no
just keep it on all right you make yeah
okay what do we call yeah do we do do we
know who this person is you'll see what
in a second hold on you'll see in a
second Bobby no I'm I'm cancelling the
Comedy Store hi um this is Bobby Lee
listen listen I'm on set I'm doing the
Rob Schneider snow show right now on
Netflix and I think I'm just not gonna
rap I'm not gonna be able to get there
on time yeah I'm not gonna be able to
make it yeah because I'm doing a show
I'm so sorry okay I'm gonna be there
this weekend okay goodbye a lot yeah
I've used diarrhea so many times I can't
use diarrhea anymore so but I am
shooting Rob Schneider show tomorrow
morning so you feel so I feel like I'm
not really lying but I am right right
yeah we heard but you know what I'm
doing it for you I think that's great
but what happens if someone from the
comics were here is this a no like I did
at that point because what Adam Iger
does he's a great club Union booger okay
but if you could cancel you can see
the consequences of the next week yeah
right so because if it's not an excuse
like this you just cancel you'll get
like two less spots the next week yeah
and I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] yeah you're
there all the time yeah yeah yeah so I'm
very good at what I do know you do don't
take it away I think I feel ever feel
that we are gonna become really good
friends I like that feeling no no be
real do you like me come on dude no no
here's the thing I know you see I know
you like it I know you seriously thought
we just met on the Comedy Jam yeah I've
met you ten million times prior to that
yeah yeah I literally never even I when
I saw you at the comedy jump like I've
never seen this guy before you used to
see all the time too it doesn't matter
because let me see something right and
you have seen me a million times
everything we've hugged and you've told
me you'd wanted to come on the crab
feast all the time at the Comedy Store
yeah but literally I didn't memorize you
that's fine yeah it would be real right
you can feel like you're being [ __ ]
uh
sad about it I'm just clarifying I'm
gonna tell you something let me clarify
something to you this is that I'm dumb
you meet a lot of people and I hope
people because they're around other
people that I that are important or
whatever mm-hmm but I don't memorize
them Yeah right
I memorized you but now once you're
memorized with me you're in it forever
and there's only 40 names I memorized so
you're amongst 40 people
what's my name Ryan Sickler all right
well you didn't pronounce it right but
still cycler what is it whatever you
said earlier Sickler sickle er tickler
how'd you say with that Japanese accent
you put on oh he's Korean but the
accident was Japanese that is true wow
you know accent I do Japanese very
throaty Laden down in here very throaty
yeah
[Music]
but you have your functor
yes your dating agency no no I'm not
dating one because I thought you said
that by ever add sex
yeah fat yeah full-blooded one yeah
sometimes it's mom killed a chicken oh
that's what that's full blood bro
because I don't think half these are
count really no yeah because they do
count though because the Asian gene is
so dominant if you're a mix agent
anything there's there's not one person
out there that's it well I should let me
take that back because there's
everything in the world but I would say
there's very few Asian Americans who
look white where there's nothing that's
agent in them right okay so what I you
understand what I'm saying hooked up
with half Asians myself and when you in
yo from yeah they do look exotic and
they do look not white but they don't
also look fully asian they look Asian
ish I know but I know but like the
vagina Ryan is like a fool Asians vagina
is a beautiful dark purple okay
the right it's a beautiful dark purple
right but I've had half I've been with
it have Asians and there's like
sometimes little light freckles and a
lighter a lighter tint to their lips
alright so it's not full but basically
what I'm trying to say god yeah right
with you on that yeah they have you know
the skin is a little more pinkish yeah
and they also lot of them are really hot
yeah when you mix white look at Steve
burn he looks white to me but that's
what I'm saying
it's is that he is 50% I don't see Asian
and Steve burn at all when you look for
but otherwise I think it's just he looks
like he's black Irish right
like that guy Tobi from the Comedy Store
the doorman the tall guy yeah he's half
yeah he's not full like me now of course
that's why when I go to clubs I go how
many Asians play your room they list me
I go full ones cuz it doesn't [ __ ]
count you think that Rob Schneider is
Asian he is but he's not full he is yes
yes alright well I'll say this
he's probably the closest white looking
Asian in entertainment that I could
think really who
joy Yokoi Brittany says Joe Coyte
location yeah he does yeah yeah Asian
yes
Hey well he's an American he loves
Mexican I don't know about my he could
probably play a Mexican but yeah yeah
yeah I mean nothing against have Asians
is this that like some against I mean
look it I'm going to show you something
okay
now I'm gonna just show you something
real quick and I'm not gay I'm not gay
you know that right mm-hmm
did you know that yeah but I'm less I
had tendencies and I'm gonna show you
something okay
there's this guy he's half Swedish in
half asian and he's a male model and his
name is Tony Thornburg okay and he's
half yeah you you don't get that with
full no of course right yeah I mean you
don't get like you know mean like this
guy right here dude it's like I am gonna
no I'm not gay but I will [ __ ] your face
yeah
oh [ __ ] don't tell anybody like if I was
in a he knows that he follows me on
Instagram I have said it many times on
podcast right cuz we have mutual friends
in Hawaii uh-huh although he lives in
Sweden right I say to Tony Thornburg
right now if we were at a [ __ ] party
that's a suck it
I suck it you don't tell nobody that's
how you'd say yeah do you realize for
Tony someone seems like yo Bobby leaves
time was like you're digging in another
podcast you know what's funny to me
about that you don't tell you tell
nobody is a friend of mine went to a
this a while ago he goes to us here in
LA he goes to a full release massage huh
and there's a hot chicks giving him this
massage and then when she's like you
know do you want anything extra he's
like yeah I want you to take care of it
so she goes I'll be right back
she leaves the room something like 65
year old lady comes in and lays a
washcloth on his stomach and she starts
jerking him off and she goes you go boy
she goes no I got a [ __ ] 60 he's like
I you have to I was at the Sacramento
arm punch line huh
and a 65 year old lady at my show this
is before my girlfriend hands me a known
a white lady and I read the note she'd
call me sometime a 65 hey Kevin Kristy
was with me and I can in this fun this
is this [ __ ] old ass white lady just
give me a no like we're gonna hook over
here he's like you should do it for the
story right you're a mess you
no the next day 5 p.m. right I'm in her
Bronco with her grandkids toys all
though and I'm sucking on her titty I
know you know I'm fingering her and she
looks old right and I'm like this is for
the story that's [ __ ] insane why no
it's great it's great it's just a little
me for me it's fun and it's funny and
IIIi don't say no to new experiences
yeah you know I try to engage and get
involved 65 is that the oldest yeah
excuse me
65 no your friend on your head no eat
your president what is it temple man I
woke up with some stress I thought you
were to cancel the work underneath I get
cold so if you do yeah yeah so you talk
about right under your nose yeah little
Hitler's in there you know and you guys
work for Trump or what Morris I was in
Dallas last week bro yeah and the club
manager and then we went to a breakfast
place and the owner of the restaurant
they're all Trump supporters and I
literally went in my head when he won I
was gonna be like out just when I run
into Trump supporter you see what I do
I'm gonna rip them a new one but when
you're actually in Texas around them you
just kind of go all right yeah you can't
say what's the point again we just don't
get like why being an ethnic person or
you know my parents are immigrants why I
can't support that [ __ ] it just to them
it's like yeah but Hillary's a [ __ ] yeah
no matter what I say he didn't disavow
the KKK yeah but Hillary's accont yeah
yeah I mean well you're bored no I'm not
bored at all I I mean I'm listening and
I'm understanding I think it should have
been Bernie you're done Bobby I'm not
mr. instructor
come on come on papa come on papa
what time was your spot ladies ticks
means they just texted me and asked me
if I was free for 10:15 spot it's not
Sunday it's not open mic but anyway my
point is no dude I've been so sick I
woke up at 6:30 that's left 2012 22 I
like I got your text but I'm so sick
right now
what's with what's going on of the cold
the cold got cold or something I haven't
eaten since yesterday do you have a
headache I wasn't driving down here I
was like I was like about the crash it
like 20 times bad Hyksos impress some
red bulls you drink a day three just now
and then Jay Larson
you know the crab feast calm pondered
all things comedy you should check out
my [ __ ] Tiger belly you know and you
guys should do my podcast one down to
two we love that you would Julie how
often do you have guests never yeah I
thought and what we do it's like we had
Margot show like that you know but we
need to get more mics you know we've
only had one guest we need to get more
mics but when we get to Mike's have you
been to the new facility yeah yeah they
have plenty of mics there when I got
bored is that where you're gonna record
from now on no we better do here right
yeah then why make a new facility that's
what we all do we have our own systems I
mean a lot of people record over there
you know they don't have their own
systems alright you know if there's
cameras in that studio we don't do
cameras if you want to go live why don't
you tell us that's what we do two
cameras how many people really sit and
watch versus listen I think people do
both like there was a lot of moments in
this podcast that if they saw a vision
facial expressions that it would just
get a extra laugh you know but you know
I mean do you do what you do you know
I'm not telling you what to do but like
I'm gonna tell you right now in terms of
white dudes doing podcast is at the top
of the line right here done thanks man
yeah it's in the top two in my opinion
to the white people you seguro and like
WTF maybe yeah orokin those are the top
four correct yeah like that yeah even
though
Ryan Sickler yeah just hit you I like
you a lot you know like you do and now
because you produce this goddamn Comedy
Jam you're gonna do more right yeah you
produce other [ __ ] right
I produce other ship I write on other
stuff too yeah yeah yeah that's what
they say but like um do you are you
gonna do like like a like a scripted
show maybe one day I would love to yeah
yeah put me in it man I love you I would
always put you in it that's why I
volunteered to take Bobby Lee when your
name came up on the story I even wrote
this is what's so funny so I wrote like
I had to give you your your notes that
you know from the network that no one
ever wants to get but I put in there I
was like you're probably be naked here
and everybody over there kept laughing
at me and I'm like listen you know he's
getting naked at some point during this
you know and I won't say anything about
the actual show but you came out to
rehearsal
you tried to blow off rehearsal mm-hmm
and I was like you were like I'm not
ready I'm pretty sure I'm not around
like that's what this sessions for you
can read off a paper mm-hmm just [ __ ]
come I don't know I think I'm not know
singing class I get an hour before they
had a trainer there huh I'm like Bobby
there's a [ __ ] horn section here just
for you you're like all right yeah came
in and you pair up no horns you were not
terrible here's so you followed Tiffany
Haddish as rehearsal and used to she
rehearsed like you saw her perform I'm
not kidding hey joel gallon looked at me
it was like that was 300% and I was like
well you better get ready for 100%
Bobbili you know you did not disappoint
and you you resilience is when you're
singing right and you see them talking
or I each other and they're writing
things down yeah like I always want to
know what the [ __ ] they're doing like
especially when you're like on a movie
set and you see video village and you do
a take especially the very first take of
a project and then they huddle around
and they you're the writing something
down you're like oh my god I'm gonna get
fired most of the time we were just
talking about what we thought was best
and the funniest that [ __ ] right but you
got naked at rehearsal and Joel is
screaming over the music pull your pants
up I'm [ __ ] dying right and then he
came out like you and the two brothers
were the brothers named Mike and Tim
what's the last names Duffy
I love them guff your brothers in you
and the old guy what's his name Mike
that him the main director guy Joel Joel
really nice - I've worked with Murray
yeah it's great
but I come liked it but like it but he
came around to talk to you and you go
right to his face you go I'm sorry I
just farted you're making me so nervous
and I just die like it's a show you know
what Bobby Lee comes in to show a big
front row and eyeing the oven he left I
don't know if he's a germaphobe he maybe
because it wasn't like he backed up to
continue to talk to you he left the room
after Bobby said that like he was just
like it's this it's you you show up
there's an old AAA saying you suit up
and show up that's the most important
thing and your ego is not your amigo
I've learned about that one he goes not
your amigo you show up even though
you're scared which was I was petrified
and I was like I'm not I can't sing I
don't know what's why agree to do this
but you show up anyway and you chew your
best and then at Showtime you have to
understand what I had to follow Tiffany
Haddish
yeah and that a follow Chris Horan Chris
Park with Richie Sambora yeah who killed
it and there was this moment right I can
wish I could explain to you what the
feeling is but it's like I don't know
what's gonna happen this might be a
disaster but here you go yeah but you
also know that you're gonna get naked in
front of the whole rig doesn't matter
because he wasn't allowed if you're
bombing and then you get naked it
doesn't work yeah the the nudity only
works is if people are on your side
already right sure I know so what I'm
saying is that I knew that from the
story to the singing that I kind of I
had them what but and I knew that I okay
I have enough confidence not to do it
but it's like you can't do it if you're
bombing yeah I've done that before when
you bombed and it makes it worse and it
makes it seem like you have no talent
whoo you crushed your story was great
your great song was great yeah your
performance was I shouldn't say that
I've been watching what so we do it was
that enough you think that's plenty
are you done your rap I'm just sweating
it like I need to eat I'm so hungry
we're gonna eat around here I'm so
[ __ ] hungry it's open now what are
you into anything I'm so there's a lot
of fun you like [ __ ] fall in and out
there's and we're right down it what is
it Washington and right here right down
right Lincoln Washington yeah there's
open well this has been a lot of fun
always thank you took quite a long time
was well worth the wait man thank you
for I'll tell you only asked me to do
the tonight on you don't even remember
anything so it doesn't matter but we've
been asking to do this play he's like
brian sickles been asking for a long
time like I did it but can I just say
something let's not make it let's make
it good let's make it good between all
three it's great no no no from now on
will we see each other cuz the last time
I saw you at the Congress or in the
lobby it was a little weird for who you
knew yeah you gave me a hug you don't
talk much and then you know I mean I
walk by so stop opened up a phenomena I
think we should just really sit you know
sink in the moment okay lock eyes love
it and just say how are you that kind of
thing that does Hollywood [ __ ] that
we've been playing one more time promote
your social media your Park and then my
podcast Tiger Valley and then have any
dates coming up you want to promote that
on the road I'm playing Schomburg improv
I'm playing Bobby's life calm is that
where your dad's our life calm and then
I'm uh yeah just other [ __ ] acting
[ __ ] and you know that's it man
well great to have you on here man are
you being sincere yeah I feel it man
good sick sick good to see you man as
always Jay Larson call me calm person
comedy and all social media Ryan Sickler
comm Ryan Sickler all social media we'll
talk to y'all next Tuesday